>> LAURA: THE G.O.P.'S
REVERSAL OF FORTUNES.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE."
JUST THREE MONTHS AGO THREE
DEMOCRATS UP AT LEAST 15 POINTS
IN THE GENERIC CONGRESSIONAL
BALLOT.
WELL NOT ANYMORE.
REUTER'S GENERIC BALLOT
HEARTENED REPUBLICANS.
AT THE BEGINNING OF MARCH
DEMOCRATS ENJOYED MORE THAN A
TEN-POINT ADVANTAGE.
NEARLY 45% SAYING THEY WOULD
VOTE FOR A DEMOCRATIC, ONLY 33%
WERE PULLED A LEVEL FOR
REPUBLICANS BUT NOW THE G.O.P.
HAS TAKEN THE LEAD.
THE LATEST ONLINE POLL SHOWS 39%
OF REGISTERED VOTERS SAYING THEY
WOULD VOTE REPUBLICAN AND JUST
36.7% SUPPORTING A DEMOCRAT.
SIX-POINT SHIFT.
SO WHY IS THIS TURNAROUND
HAPPENING?
BECAUSE REPUBLICANS PRETTY MUCH
STAYING ON OFFENSE AND
SUPPORTING GENERALLY NOT
UNDERMINING THE PRESIDENT ON KEY
ISSUES.
BY WORKING TO KEEP THIS ECONOMY
GOING, DISMANTLING THE
REGULATORY SUPERSTATE THAT HURTS
OUR INNOVATORS AND
ENTREPRENEURS, BY NOT DRAGGING
US INTO MORE SERIOUS MILITARY
CONFLICTS, BY REFUSING TO BUCKLE
ON IMMIGRATION, AT LEAST SO FAR.
THE G.O.P. IS ACTUALLY GAINING
MOMENTUM.
ACCORDING TO THE COOK POLITICAL
REPORT CALIFORNIA'S 39TH AND
49TH DISTRICT HAVE BOTH SHIFTED
FROM LEAN DEMOCRATIC TO TOSS UP.
NEBRASKA'S SECOND DISTRICT MOVED
FROM TOSS-UP TO A LEANING
REPUBLICAN AND SOUTH CAROLINA'S
FIFTH DISTRICT MOVED FROM LIKELY
REPUBLICAN TO SOLID REPUBLICAN.
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE THIS HAS
THROWN THE DEMOCRATS INTO A FULL
ON FROTHY PANIC.
THE PARTY OF FAILED IDEAS HAS
ISSUED A NEW ANTICORRUPTION
MESSAGE.
THAT'S GOING TO BE WHAT DRIVES
THE MIDTERMS FOR THEM.
THEY HOPE IT'S GOING TO BRING
THEM SUCCESS.
IT'S BEEN SAID THAT IMITATION IS
THE SINCEREST FORM OF FLATTERY,
I WONDER WHAT PLAGIARISM GETS
YOU.
DEMOCRATIC LEADERS IN A NEW MEMO
KIND OF SEEM TO BE CHANNELING
TRUMP.
THEY ARE WRITING THIS.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE SICK OF
GETTING A RAW DEAL FROM
WASHINGTON.
DOES THIS ALL SOUNDS VAGUELY
FAMILIAR?
IT IS.
>> THE PEOPLE GOT A RAW DEAL AND
THEY DESERVE SO MUCH BETTER.
OUR GOVERNMENT IS BEING EATEN
ALIVE.
KICK THE CROOKS OUT OF
WASHINGTON, D.C.
>> LAURA: IF YOU CAN'T BEAT
THEM, REPEAT THEM I GUESS.
TWO MAJOR PROBLEMS WITH THE
DEMOCRATS ARE ADOPTING AN
ANTICORRUPTION PLATFORM BECAUSE
THEY ARE THE PARTY OF
CORRUPTION.
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE THAT
BROUGHT YOU OBAMA'S WEAPONIZED
IRS TO TARGET CONSERVATIVES
YEARS AGO.
SAME PARTY THAT CIRCLED THE
WAGONS AROUND HILLARY CLINTON'S
PAY TO PLAY SCHEME AT THE
STATE DEPARTMENT WHERE
BLACKBERRY PHONES WERE SMASHED
AND HARD DRIVES WERE RAISED BY
BLEACH BID.
LET'S NOT FORGET THE PARTY OF
DEBBIE WASSERMAN SCHULTZ WHO,
WHILE RUNNING THE DNC, EMPLOYED
AN I.T. SPECIALIST WOULD TRY TO
FLEE TO PAKISTAN AFTER HE WIRED
MONEY THERE.
MONEY FEDERAL PROSECUTORS SAY
WAS OBTAINED ILLEGALLY.
A FEDERAL GRAND JURY INDICTED
HIM AND HIS WIFE ON FOUR COUNTS
LAST SUMMER, BANK FRAUD AND
CONSPIRACY CHARGES.
AND THIS IS THE PARTY, BY THE
WAY, THAT'S GOING TO ROOT OUT
CORRUPTION.
THE CLINTONS AND THEIR POLITICAL
SPAWN ARE SO UNSCRUPULOUS THAT
SUPPORTERS OF BERNIE SANDERS
FILED A CLASS ACTION LAWSUIT
AGAINST THE DNC FOR RIGGING THE
PRIMARY IN HILLARY'S FAVOR.
DON'T YOU GET AN AIR OF
DESPERATION HAS BEGUN TO SETTLE
OVER THE DEMOCRATS?
BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT THEY WERE
GUARANTEED TO STRIKE ELECTORAL
GOLD IN NOVEMBER.
CONGRESSMAN AL GREEN, A TEXAS
DEMOCRAT IS PROMISING THAT IF
THEY TAKE CONTROL OF THE HOUSE
"THERE'S A GOOD LIKELIHOOD THERE
WILL BE ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT
BROUGHT AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.
THAT'S IT?
THAT'S HER PLAN?
HOW'S THAT GOING TO GROW FOLDERS
401(K)S OR KEEP OUR
MANUFACTURING BOOM GOING?
IMPEACHMENT IS NOT A PRO-GROWTH
PLATFORM, KIDS.
AND IF THAT DOESN'T GET OUT THE
VOTE, SOME LIBERAL FOOT SOLDIERS
HOPE THAT ATTEMPTS AT COMEDY
WELL.
DEPUTY CHAIR OF THE DEMOCRATIC
NATIONAL COMMITTEE, CONGRESSMAN
KEITH ELLISON, HE DONNED A BLOND
WIG TO IMPERSONATE THE PRESIDENT
RECENTLY.
WARNING, COVER YOUR PET'S EARS
AND PUT MASKING TAPE ON THE
WINDOWPANES.
>> ROBERT MUELLER.
I HATE THAT ROBERT MUELLER.
I'M FIRING ROBERT MUELLER.
ON FIRING ROBERT MUELLER.
>> LAURA: HE WILL NOT BE
SINGING AT HAMILTON ANYTIME
SOON.
THE TWO HAS FLAT, OFF KEY AS THE
REST OF THE DEMOCRATIC MESSAGE.
MY FRIENDS, THIS SHOULD BE
FAIRLY EASY FOR THE REPUBLICANS.
THERE'S A GREAT SENSE OF
OPTIMISM IN THE COUNTRY.
IT'S A GREAT TIME TO BE AN
AMERICAN.
I THINK THERE'S NO BETTER TIME
THEN MAYBE IN THE '80S DURING
REAGAN.
SO IT'S TIME TO DOUBLE DOWN ON
THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
SUPPORT THE PRESIDENT'S POPULIST
PRO-GROWTH AGENDA.
THE G.O.P. AT THE SAME TIME MUST
ALSO AVOID ANY SELF-INFLICTED
WOUNDS BEFORE THE MIDTERM,
PROMOTING OR PASSING AN AMNESTY
PLAN FOR GOING WEEK ON CHINA.
THAT COULD ACTUALLY DISHEARTEN
THE BASE.
IT COULD BREAK FAITH WITH THE
BLUE-COLLAR WORKERS WHO SWEPT
THE PRESIDENT AND THE G.O.P.
INTO OFFICE AND PUT AGAIN IF YOU